[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi
23 mai l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois qu'une exposition
originale sur l'art numérique est post
digital c'est l'une des spécialités de
l'ordre one more un artiste aux
multiples casquettes que nous
découvrirons dans cette édition ce
dimanche 26 mai nous n'oublierons pas de
voter pour les européennes mais aussi de
souhaiter une bonne fête à nos mamans
pour l'occasion la ville de vivre
propose un marché des créateurs nous en
parlerons en plateau avec nos invités
pour la première fois depuis 20 ans le
championnat de france de gymnastique par
équipes revient en ile de france et est
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que ça se
passe de vendredi à dimanche une
exposition haute en couleurs celles de
notre monde moderne réalisée avec un
ordinateur pour parler identité et
technologie lors de wine more présente
ses oeuvres à l'espace philippe noiret
aux clayes-sous-bois jusqu'au 2 juin
reportage de belhani poquet des tableaux
aux couleurs aussi vive que leur message
il ne s'agit pas de toile mais
d'impression sur plaque aluminium khroma
luxe dessinée à l'ordinateur en octobre
2014 alors que je n'avais jamais ni pain
ni dessinée ni quoi que ce soit du genre
je me suis mis à faire lors d'une fête
de famille des dessins et des peintures
sur des tablettes et mon beau père qui
est peintre assez dur à un moment donné
ma ma vue faire il m'a dit pas mal tu es
merde alors j'ai contenu
l'exposition est en deux parties suivant
ces deux techniques de création après
l'impression l'oeuvre poste digitales
des oeuvres conçues en numérique
réinterpréter à l'acrylique sur toile
je voulais absolument remettre de
l'humain dans le digital
alors c'est complètement paradoxal par
rapport au fait des tartines numérique
mais bon je trouve c'est vraiment
important que les gens se posent la
question une réflexion sur la place du
numérique dans notre époque et sur
l'identité on retrouve régulièrement sur
ses oeuvres un même personnage
le boat idoc le canard au noeud papillon
ce que je veux montrer c'est que ce
canard qui n'est rien qui n'a pas
dieu qui n'a pas de bouche tout le monde
peut se projeter dedans et donc c'est
votre identité propre en tant que
spectateur qui peut émerger
il a 7 milliards d'identité pour
l'instant est sage de l'ani pas
évidemment que chacun on a notre propre
identité
par contre on peut pas dire et je pense
c'est vraiment une illusion qui a une
identité de groupe
la parcelle de l'être humain ces deux
dernières années de travail de l'artiste
exposé réfléchissent la lumière avec
leurs couleurs pour que celle ci pousse
votre propre réflexion
[Musique]
dimanche c'est la fête des mères et si
vous n'avez toujours pas trouvé la bonne
idée et souhaitait éviter le collier de
pâtes ou pire l'aspirateur évident pour
vous propose un marché des créateurs
spéciale avec nous en plateau suffit
cependant elle deuxième adjointe au
maire de ville pris en charge de la
communication la sécurité le protocole
émanant vallée créatrice de bijoux en
bois bonjour jours alors pourquoi ce
marché artisanal qui fête les mamans à
wimereux
bonjour parce que ça aurait déjà
plusieurs années qu'on organise un
marché qui fête les mamans
ça fait déjà mais mon premier mandat on
le faisait déjà on fait pareil au moment
de noël et c'est pour nous très
important au printemps de faire une
manifestation qui honore les mamans
c'est l'occasion de faire plusieurs
animations fait sa sueur pour la
première fois par qu'on trouvait ça sur
toute la journée en général c'était que
le matin donc là on s'est dit que ça
valait le coup vu le succès que ça peut
avoir de faire ça de 9h à 17h et donc on
y tient les élus sont tous présents et
on a pas mal d'animations avec le maire
on offre une rose notamment à toutes les
mamans vide prochaine qui viennent nous
voir et ça on le fait déjà depuis un
paquet d'années on y tient énormément
beaucoup de compacts une grosse et j'ai
entendu parler de coccinelles de larves
de coccinelles or oui on aura cette
année pour la deuxième édition l'année
dernière ça avait lieu au moment de la
fête de la ville là on en a profité par
rapport à la saisonnalité savait plus de
sens que ça se passe la femme est on
offre alors y adapter un peu pas
illimité parce qu'on a un certain nombre
de boîtes mais on offre des coccinelles
qui sont justement pour lutter contre
les rênes
et east ici donc c'est un anti puces
cours naturel et donc on off pour la
deuxième année consécutive la salle eu
raison de la fête la fête des mères des
pucerons ville provient qui pour
encourager l'ensemble des villes projet
n'est plus du tout utiliser de
pesticides sur la ville comme new déjà
la ville on est en zéro phyto au niveau
des services des espaces verts
on encourage le plus possible cette
démarche-là sur les progrès de
l'animation des exposants des créateurs
combien à peu près il y en a une petite
vingtaine quasiment voyait quasiment 20
qui viennent à la fois de villepreux
c'est vraiment des deux locales et
d'ile-de-france donc des régionaux tout
ça pour vous dire que d'autres wax et
aussi on en revient c'est très à la mode
actuellement et c'est très justifiées on
est vraiment en circuit court là aussi
le circuit court ce n'est pas que
l'alimentaire donc il n'ya pas de
produits qui viennent de chine
il n'y a pas de produits qui viennent de
l'autre bout du monde on est sur du
local on a en circuit court en
développement justement développement
l'irl encourageant les initiatives
locales comme manon justement d'aller et
venir parmi tous les exposants vous
serez là mais non pas les niveaux qu'est
ce que vous nous proposez et bien moi
j'ai un stand de bijoux des bijoux et
écologique c'est à dire que je vais
essayer d'utiliser des matières vraiment
qu'ils soient naturels comme des fleurs
du bois des j'aime aussi et j'essaye
vraiment le plus possible qu'il n'y ait
pas d'échelle donc j'évite vraiment tout
ce qui va être plastique même mes
petites pochettes sont faites de l'ain
et je fais tout chez moi donc circuit
très court pour le coup sur le stand la
de samedi voilà il ya que moi qui fut
dans ma dans ma société et je le fais
tout chez moi tout seul le site internet
et les bijoux et voilà donc fait d'une
maison du maison pur et dur donc
justement pourra retrouver toutes vos
créations aussi sur votre page facebook
que je crois et donc vous êtes là samedi
donc le marché c'est une vers 17 heures
9h10 sitter et on encourage fortement
des démarches comme manon stel et
régionales à 23 ans
si une toute jeune chef d'entreprise
donc on tient vraiment à pousser au
maximum les jeunes créateurs à
villepreux
c'est notre rôle aussi en tant qu'élu de
vous voir ce genre d'initiative
on est très très heureux qu'elle soit là
samedi avec la mairie de lille brute
fait très bien son travail
si elle d'ailleurs ciblé qui m'avait
trouvé sur facebook parce que j'avais
posté une petite photo et quelques temps
j'avais eu un stand dans la ville et
elle m'a contacté et depuis ils ne se
quittent pas c'était de dire qu'elle a
vraiment pris sous son aile mais c'est
super voilà la mairie vraiment actif de
ce côté là très bien on vous retrouve ce
samedi donc pour ce marché spécial fête
des mères à villepreux de 9 heures à 17
heures et avant la fête des mères il ya
la fête des voisins ce vendredi 24 mai
l'idée vient d'une bande de copains du
xviie arrondissement de paris la toute
première a eu lieu en 1999
la fête des voisins fête donc cette
année ses 20 ans elle a regroupé 9
millions de fêtards l'année dernière en
france pour cette édition 2010 9 22
commune yvelinoise se sont inscrits
auprès de l'association initiatrice et
se font les relais de cette fête
chaque citoyen pouvait récupérer des
kits en mairie afin d'organiser au mieux
les festivités pour vous évader jusqu'au
cambodge voici votre rubrique dans les
salles saint-quentinoise de patrick
jacques de dixmude cette semaine à
l'espace philippe noiret retrouver le
film final donc un premier long métrage
d'animation du réalisateur de nidau on
propose lors de deux séances
exceptionnelles en ce dimanche à 18h30
et lundi à 14 heures donc c'est un
horaire un peu spécial on reçoit à cette
occasion le réalisateur et le producteur
du film
lors d'une rencontre avec des collégiens
mais c'est ouvert à tout le monde voilà
mais ça me tenait à coeur de proposer à
ce public là également
donc c'est un premier long métrage qui a
reçu
cristal au festival a ainsi donc
meilleur film d'animation et le
réalisateur s'inspire de l'histoire de
sa mère sarah con que le destin d'une
jeune mère cambodgienne qui se retrouve
privé de son fils au début de la
révolution khmer rouge
voilà donc c'est un film très fort très
bouleversant qu'on a envie de défendre
cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
[Applaudissements]
je vais l'armée chaud
je te le prendre en cas le parti
communiste a réuni tout le peuple peut
il sera bon avec vous un peu nouveau tu
crois que j'y retrouvais souvent tap le
droit d'abandonner chou
[Musique]
à
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines promet du
spectacle de vendredi à dimanche
pas de cyclisme et de la gymnastique le
club de gymnastique elancourt maurepas
accueille les championnats de france par
équipes
une première pour le club qui fait ainsi
revenir la compétition en ile-de-france
cela faisait 20 ans que ces championnats
n'avait pas eu lieu dans la région la
jem a même désespoir cinq de leurs
athlètes sont revenus avec des médailles
aux derniers championnats de france
individuels un record pour le club
la compétition commence vendredi dès 8
heures 40 jusqu'au dimanche 14 heures 30
600 scolaires pourront découvrir la
gymnastique avec de la pratique à lille
de loisirs et bien sûr assister à la
compétition le vendredi un échange est
même prévu avec des athlètes le
responsable de l'organisation était sur
le plateau du 7-8 journal ce mardi 21 b
c'est à peu près 250 équipes ça
représente mille cinq cents gymnastes
qui viennent de toute la france y
compris de l'autre mère voilà et on est
à peu près un peu plus de 200 bénévoles
actuellement sur le championnat de
france il ya la division 2 1 assist donc
que la division une étant la meilleure
des divisions nationales
donc en effet on a des athlètes de haut
niveau qui seront là on a des jeunes
filles l'équipe de france qui seront
également là puisqu'elles font partie
des équipes dans la division nationale
une
voilà donc on aura deux normalement du
bon niveau ce week end à quelques
semaines de la coupe du monde on
commence par encourager les yvelinoises
samedi 1er juin c'est la journée du foot
féminin
cette année c'était long cours qui
accueillent ces finales des différents
championnats féminins du district des
yvelines les filles ou foot les u11 f et
les u13 f le matin et toutes les finales
départementales l'après midi pour une
grande finale de la coupe des yvelines
seniors f à 16h45
la présidente de la section football de
l'olympique ce parti club d'elancourt
vous donne rendez vous c'est ouvert à
tout le monde donc là les clubs se
soient inscrits pour venir participer
mais effectivement c'est la fête du foot
il va y avoir des ateliers donc des
ateliers techniques des quizz il va y
avoir un stand coupe du monde où toutes
les petites vont pouvoir venir il va y
avoir on va essayer de faire une petite
surprise pour pour l'entrée des seniors
foot à 11 pour la finale mais n'avaient
pas leur plein d'animations ça met une
belle journée et le football féminin ces
jeux
comment le thème de notre 7,8 dossier du
mois vous pouvez le retrouver en replay
sur notre site internet et maintenant
direction probants pour voir de drôles
d'oiseaux
[Musique]
la saison est ouverte pour le spectacle
les aigles des remparts de philippe
hertel plus de vingt espèces de rapaces
différents se produisent à provins
reportage au coeur de la volière de
maylis trois de nos confrères la grand
paris des aigles pêcheurs venus
d'amérique du nord
des hiboux d'asie centrale ou encore des
carrats cajas d'amérique latine d'un
venu à provins dans la volerie d'une
vingtaine d'espèces de rapaces ici comme
chaque matin les oiseaux sont
chouchoutés avant le spectacle et c'est
surtout la pesée qui sera déterminante
pour mener à bien la représentation pour
fait leur volent pour se nourrir
donc il est important pour nous deux
de connaître l'état de forme c'est parce
que le haut vol avec un poids d'athlètes
et cette pesée nous permettent de savoir
si l'oiseau va voir oui de voler
aujourd'hui puisque me présenter
quotidiennement en spectacle et ça lui
permet également de déterminer quelle
quantité de nourriture on va devoir lui
donner puisque on les nourrit pendant le
vol pendant le spectacle puisque à
chaque arrivée sur le gant il trouve un
petit morceau de jambe mais la pesée
donc nous permettre également de savoir
qu'est ce qu'on va leur donner s'ils
sont un peu trop aux emplois autrement
car les oiseaux doivent être prêts pour
le spectacle de cet après midi ils vont
se présenter à un public heureux de
découvrir l'histoire de l'art de la
fauconnerie
[Musique]
chaque année près de 90000 spectateurs
viennent admirer les aigles des remparts
une heure de show qui retrace le lien
indéniable entre les oiseaux et les
hommes ont des bars avec le vol du
faucon dans un tableau du moyen orient
ensuite on transporte plus vite le
spectateur dans le médiéval puisque
c'est l'âge d'or de la fauconnerie en
europe va retrouver des petits oiseaux
de chasse comme les pitbulls et bien
évidemment on a un tableau aussi kazakh
parce que dans les steppes d'asie
centrale il y a beaucoup de chasse à
l'aigle donc c'est là qu'on rencontre
aussi l'harmonie entre l'homme loiseau
et le cheval donc effectivement
transport de petites saynètes en scène
est comme ça et en mettant en évidence
ou si le vol de chaque oiseau
on transporte le visiteur dans
différentes ambiances un spectacle au
plus près des rapaces et des fauconniers
allez découvrir jusqu'en novembre dans
la vie médiévale de provins c'est la fin
de ce numéro bonne fête à toutes les
mamans et plus particulièrement à la
mienne bonne semaine sur tv 78
m
[Musique]
ouais
oh
[Musique]